because i wasn't sure i was ever going
to speak to you again i know i know
yeah like the fact that i'm speaking to
you again
is a miracle will and
jada pinkett smith breaking their
silence after august alcina not only
claimed he had a relationship with her
but that will jada's husband of 22 years
was on board with it i actually sat down
with will and had a conversation he gave
me his blessing
jada opened up on her facebook watch
show red table talk
with will by her side and confirmed
august
wasn't lying about their relationship
revealing she and will were
separated at the time you and i were
going through a very
difficult time yeah and we decided i was
done with you
yeah you kicked me to the curb with you
yeah
marriages have that though yeah we
basically we broke up
we decided that we were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to make myself
happy
that's when jada said she started what
she called an entanglement with the 27
year old about five years ago
but she said that whole august asking
will for permission thing
never happened one of the things that
was kind of swirling in the press
about you giving permission which
is uh you know the only person that can
give permission
in in that particular circumstances
myself yes jada said after a while the
relationship with august
fizzled out on his terms as i came
through
and started to realize certain things
about you and i he decided
to break all communication with me right
which was totally understandable right
um and i let that be and hadn't talked
to him since
yeah so it is a little weird that all
this stuff is coming out now since this
was
yeah cause for me this was years ago
right yeah the 48 year old made it
pretty clear
she never wanted to comment on any of it
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a home wrecker
which he's not of course this whole
thing started in june when the singer
sat down with angela yee to talk about
his new album the product 2
state of emergency and straight up
dropped a bomb claiming that those
long-standing rumors that he and jada
were a thing
weren't just rumors i totally
gave myself to that relationship for
years of my life you know and i
truly and really really
deeply loved and have a ton of love
for her i devoted myself
to it i gave my full self to it so much
so to
the point that i can die right now
and be okay with knowing that
i truly gave myself to somebody right
and will and jada found their
way back to each other with jada
confessing she tried out the
relationship with august in an
attempt to heal herself figuring out she
actually needed to do that soul
searching on her own
now the couple says they're totally
committed to each other
for better or worse 25 years and
counting
hmm we ride together we gotta go
together
bad marriage for life
you